and uh nate you mentioned uh last week
about the polar express
conductor styles yeah so they had this
imaginary polar express it wasn't an
actual train but it was so much fun
after meeting with the elves and some of
the other train conductors
and as a choir from the las vegas
academy wrapped up their holiday carols
[Music]
it was time to fire up the polar express
engine
at the cleverly disguised cimarron rose
community center's sports courts on ann
road dear durango
the elves danced
hot chocolate was served
kids and families danced and sang then
[Music]
the big man showed up
and the kids snapped pictures with him
before we all went home so just a really
incredible idea that somebody had up
there at the cimarron rose community
center uh erin clark runs and she said
kristin came up with this idea and they
said you're crazy there's no way you can
turn sports courts into an imaginary
train but they did they took sheets of
black corrugated plastic they've created
that sort of engine
and then they put the they were ahead
the overhead canopy so there we were on
an imaginary train ride tickets tickets
get your tickets
it's christmas magic and the kids they
were all aboard the parents had a good
time the hot chocolates singing along
with the christmas carols just a really
cute idea for a neighborhood community
center around hand road and durango
five bucks a ticket that's it